if the FBI hasn't already it really
should open an investigation into
radical trumpist Maga Republican member
of Congress Madison cawthorne who is now
coyly threatening Bloodshed if the
elections remain as he calls it rigged
this is absolutely horrifying stuff from
any citizen of the United States but
this is an elected member of Congress
Congressman Madison cawthorne republican
from North Carolina on Sunday this is
just a couple days ago falsely suggested
that elections in the United States are
rigged and said there will be Bloodshed
if the country's electoral system
continues on its current path given the
context of January 6 that should be seen
and treated as a threat cawthorne a
freshman lawmaker and pro-trump star of
the right made the remarks during an
event at the Macon County Republican
party headquarters in Franklin North
Carolina on Sunday night
the video has been taken offline as of
Tuesday Morning from the event's
Facebook page but we have it we have the
video and here is Madison cawthorne
threatening Bloodshed should be expelled
from Congress and investigated by the
FBI he might end up getting reelected in
November of 22. take a listen
because you know if our election systems
continue to be rigged and continue to be
stolen it's going to lead to one place
and it's Bloodshed so remember it's a
false premise the election wasn't stolen
Joe Biden won by quite a few uh quite a
few electoral votes as many as Trump won
by in 2016 and by far more in the
popular vote but he is basing on that
false premise the idea that there will
be Bloodshed and I will tell you as much
as I am willing to defend our Liberty at
all costs there's nothing that I would
dread doing more than having to pick up
arms against the fellow Americans what
in a way that we even have recourse
against that is if we all passionately
demand that we have election Security in
all 50 states so that clip was
ultimately taken down
uh because it obviously doesn't look
good the FBI should be investigating
Madison cawthorne understand the
totality of cawthorne he has said that
he is sometimes armed on the floor of
the House of Representatives since metal
detectors have been put in I don't know
what the latest is on that he attempted
to bring a gun onto a plane try to carry
it on with him said oops that was a
mistake and now is saying there is going
to be Bloodshed if our elections
continue to be stolen which of course
they are not the FBI should investigate
this is trumpian Terror and I don't know
how anybody can feel even remotely
optimistic about the future of this
country when we have elected officials
sworn to uphold the Constitution who
were talking about taking up arms
against other Americans it's sort of
what the calls are coming from inside
the house moment here this is language
that historically
you would expect from two places one
from actual fascist dictatorships or
second in situations where the
government has actually lost its
legitimacy and its ability to have an
election this is not the second one
right as far as elections go our
government does many bad things but as
far as elections go we still have
elections that are basically Fair
elections meaning
I wonder if this is a guy who has
delusions of the first one a fascist
dictatorship dictatorship it is not just
that these clowns and I'm talking about
Madison cawthorne and Marjorie Taylor
green and Lauren bobert and Louis
gohmert and Matt Gates and the whole
list of them it's not just that they're
unqualified for the job of being elected
officials their rhetoric is completely
anti-American and borderline traitorous
and not only do they have no business
being lawmakers these are folks that
should be under investigation for their
allusions to violence that they
continually make so that's Madison
cawthorne and we're going to continue to
follow it
let's be honest most healthy snack bars
are not exciting like my live streams
and that's why you should check out our
sponsor monk pack monk pack keto nut and
Seed bars are sweet and delicious soft
and chewy with a big satisfying crunch
but each bar has just one gram of sugar
two to three net carbs and just 150
calories so it's great for someone on a
keto or low carb diet or even if you
just want a tasty sweet snack without
the sugar monk pack keto nut and Seed
bars come in great flavors like sea salt
dark chocolate caramel sea salt or
caramel you choose and peanut butter
dark chocolate I always have a box of
these ready to go in my pantry which is
easy when you do the optional monthly
subscription which also saves you ten
percent if you have a sweet tooth this
is the way to indulge without the guilt
whether it's for breakfast or in the car
or after a workout go to monkpak.com the
link is under the this video and you'll
save twenty percent when you use code
Pacman at checkout